when did you come to this project and
what was your reaction when you saw all
the elements at play well I came to this
project originally on Ballet Russe dan
and Dana had were making Ballet Russe
and they asked me to come in and assist
them during that process they said to me
how does this sound as an idea and I
said well that's a pretty amazing idea
how you gonna do that in 1998 you can
see that last quote in La Bocca Sarada
no Anton mas Gus we were down in 1998
doing nothing related to this movie a
friend of ours had received a National
Science Foundation grant to make an
interactive curriculum for middle school
kids on evolution and natural selection
and it had a video component like little
clips that you would roll over to see if
there's an adaptive trait in the species
and our friend Doug and hired me to do
the camerawork and Dana to do the sound
normally we just do it for ourselves but
when a friend calls up and says hey
would you work for me and come to the
Galapagus and get paid sure great gig
but we weren't aware of human habitation
i'm Galapagus at all and had no idea
about this story particularly until Dana
who is a phenomenally avid reader
reached up on to the bookshelf behind
that little dining table in the dining
area of our small boat and pulled off
one of all of four books on that shelf
and then I saw her jaw dropping I
thought what she just find in this book
it was called the enchanted Islands and
it's a book that's about the human
history of the islands and it was just
shocking to me that there was enough
human history of the Galapagos Islands
to fill a book because there's no
indigenous people there but as you see
in this film people started coming and
most of them started coming in the 20s
and 30s and most of them were Europeans
even though the islands are actually
owned by Ecuador so I flipped open this
book and started thumbing through it and
the third or fourth chapter was called
murder in paradise and what Dan about
burying the lede
it was completely buried um what Dan was
kind enough not to share but I will now
help myself
my-my sort of dirty secret is that I
true crime and so you know it was this
one-two punch of how there are people
that live here there's enough of a
history that there's a book I'm on it
and there's this 12 page episode um that
like literally every sentence in this 12
pages was so dynamic and you saw how
colorful these characters are I couldn't
believe they actually existed and so I
said Dan you got to read this this
chapter and then at that moment our
incredible naturalist guide who lives on
the islands and and has since become a
friend but he turned to us and he said
well you know the old lady which is what
he called Margaret that murder lady is
still alive and at that moment I became
determined to stop on this island of
Floreana during our two-week journey
down there and we were lucky enough to
have tea and cookies with with Margaret
but Miguel our guide said I'm very good
friends with her and if you Dana I know
you're it's gonna be right on the tip of
your tongue the whole time were in her
presence to ask her about what went on
and who did what to whom and if you do I
will kill you and he carefully seated
himself right next to me with a knife
exactly his gun was hidden um and he he
glared at me every time I open my mouth
so I kind of didn't ever say anything
and we just kept Margaret talking and
mostly what she talked about in those
days which were only a couple of years
before she passed away were things like
the famous people like you know
Roosevelt who had visited the island and
what she had done and I mean she really
had become the queen of Floreana by that
point she had completely taken over the
Baroness's role then you had the most
astounding walk of finding this footage
shot by the way by Alan Hancock for whom
Hancock Park is named the oil man so
here's definitely a look that wasn't a
stroke here we go another massive stroke
of luck and within documentary films
especially the so much depends on
happenstance coincidence and in this
case the same friend Doug white I was
starting another science education
project working with a professor at USC
who's now in Arkansas bill McComas and
bill also was an
of Galapagus had taken students down on
trips natural history trips and he was
the one who told Doug who told us about
the archive and Doheny library that was
for lack of funding falling apart
contained all of the five years worth of
Captain Allen Hancock's explorations
down the coast of the Americas past
Galapagos to the Marquesas with the
Galapagos human histories capturing his
attention once this Ritter Straub
stories began to develop and we
approached the archive and melinda Hayes
the archivist knew that we would be
treating the material kindly and she
worked to get us the exclusive rights to
that footage in exchange for giving them
a copy and we coast through the Tallis
any as much as we could which is every
frame of which is on screen there but as
each reel began to spool out slowly but
surely we realized that we had a gold
mine on our hands the rolls were so
wonderful and the story is so fantastic
and one of the things you know they had
already met Kate and we talked about
what part Kate should play and then of
course once you have Kate that helps you
enormous Lee but we wanted to get other
you know European actors and people that
were the right ethnicity for each of the
roles and it was just so much fun to get
on the phone with the agents and pitch
this story you know time and time again
because people were astounded we it was
quite a coincidence through a connection
of Ballet Russe who this man was ned and
this is still the exact director of the
Sydney Theatre Company and so when Kate
was coming over to shoot blue Jasmine in
San Francisco where we're based he
connected the two of us we hit it off
right away with Kate with her husband
Andrew with the three young boys we just
had a great time
across that month kate saw the movie a
rough cut and Dana and I decided at that
point on this with this new friendship
we we didn't want to impose on the
friendship turns out later neither did
kate want to impose on us to say i'll
take a role so we thought well just
let's we're doing this for the
friendship and we let it go when we met
Margie for the first time we came down
to her house and she heard that we knew
Kate
the words were you two are idiots if you
don't go back to your friend arguably
one of the greatest actresses in the
world and ask her to do the role so I
mean and that's what really prodded us
to go back and get it's not just having
the ideas its prodding everybody along
and talking people into things and and
you know and figuring out you know how
to pull something together the other
thing is that I you know very conscious
of the fact and I had worked on one
other documentary into the arms of
strangers that actually won the Oscar to
help them find the narrator is that the
higher profile people you can get
connected you know it's hard for these
films to find audiences and you want it
to have a life so you try to sort of
ramp amp it up the actors really all
were fantastic and really really into it